[Musica]
Vorrei partire da evocando un'immagine
in tutti voi l'immagine che vorrei che
no potessimo proiettare è quella del di
un muratore
ci siamo bene nel così io immagino che
nel collettivo umano il muratore
che cosa Che cosa ci fa pensare a
qualcuno sicuramente che fa un lavoro
duro
ad un uomo segnato dalla fatica dalle
mani callose e ce lo immaginiamo appunto
con una cazzuola in mano è una cuffa di
cemento
e in effetti è così Ma la domanda la
riflessione che vorrei fare è
differente è Ma che cosa sono una
persona che fa il mestiere del muratore
ed è una domanda che non mi sono fatta
oggi la sono fatta qualche tempo fa Ecco
un muratore probabilmente una persona
che svolge il mestiere da muratore
probabilmente cosa sogna sogna di poter
fare il meglio per sé per la propria
famiglia per i propri figli magari
arrivando a sognare di costruirsi una
casa tutta sua è una storia che è un po'
conosciamo No una casa tutta sua per
poter avere poi la soddisfazione di dire
Guarda questa l'ho fatta io l'ho
costruita con il mio sudore con la mia
fatica con i miei sforzi e con il duro
lavoro
sì è proprio dai sogni che desidero
partire Anzi metterò anche una slide
visto che è stata nominata a Dubai ho
voluto testimonianza portare la vetta
più alta del mondo nella quale stiamo
già operando ma
parto dai sogni Perché i sogni Da dove è
partito tutto
che cosa sono sono l'idea e da lì l'idea
Vediamo se ce la faccio
che tutti gli uomini
desiderano hanno dei sogni e desiderano
realizzarli è la differenza però Che
cosa la fa la fa Casomai se questi
uomini incontrano altre persone magari
imprenditori
che non solo li ascoltano ma
decidono di accompagnarli
di dargli strumenti e di accompagnarvi
nella vera e propria realizzazione
Infatti questa storia Comincia proprio
da qui per il 2007 io non conoscevo
assolutamente il mondo dell'edilizia
arrivavo da un altro settore certo per
risorse umane e
mi occupavo di formazione di motivazione
delle persone però nel 2007 è iniziato
questo appassionante sogno che è quello
che mi ha portato ad essere qui oggi e
che non è un sogno che non che è
incessante continuo e ed è cominciato
con un incontro proprio sui banchi di
scuola di un imprenditore che io
definisco illuminato a non illuminato
per L'idea geniale che aveva di cambiare
il modo di fare cultura No cioè di
cambiare la cultura di fare edilizia nel
mondo
non era illuminato per questo Certo
Quella era stata la sua idea geniale Sì
perché infatti un po' per caso è un po'
per fame aveva trovato un sistema
geniale per ripristinare e restaurare
gli edifici senza l'utilizzo del
ponteggi E certo questa è una cosa
geniale però vedete poco fa lo hanno
ricordato Io ho conosciuto questo
imprenditore nel 2006 e nel 2007 ho
intrapreso con lui questo viaggio ma lui
l'azienda l'aveva già aperta dal 94
e quindi l'altra domanda l'altra
riflessione che dovremmo farci è perché
dal 94 al 2006 si era cresciuto aveva
realizzato Certo prima era da solo ma
quando l'ho conosciuto io aveva 12
persone
Quindi al 94 al 2006 12 persone e vi
assicuro che quelle 12 persone non erano
come gli apostoli No erano anche un po'
differenti E allora Che cos'è che è
successo su quei banchi di scuola lui
illuminato perché da imprenditore veniva
a studiare io allora no ero nel in una
che è business School a Bologna e lì a
studiare perché non capiva Come mai
questa idea tanto geniale non riusciva a
prendere forma e Beh cos'è che c'è
dietro no un'idea seppur geniale
ci sono le persone e l'unico valore di
un'idea restano le persone per poterla
mettere in campo e attuare senza quella
sai di idee geniali ce ne sono tante Ed
ecco che arrivo al perché è stato un
imprenditore illuminato perché come
pochi imprenditori
qui sicuramente ce ne sono di illuminati
come Riccardo pensano
di potere di doversi formare di doversi
allenare per migliorare alcune delle
cose che non che non funzionano magari
di apprendere alcune che non sanno
proprio ma quelli ancora più illuminati
sono quelli come Riccardo che capiscono
che se non hanno delle particolari no
abitudini operative che favoriscono la
relazione la crescita degli altri
possono trovare però persone in grado di
farlo
e qui arriva il primo punto Riccardo
aveva una grande meta però da bravo
imprenditore era capace a condividerla
ed è essenziale perché vedi anch'io no
che ero di avevo la mia è la mia meta
era completamente differente dalla sua
la sua era trasformare il modo di fare
edilizia in Italia nel mondo la mia il
maggior numero di persone possibile che
lucidando il proprio potenziale
migliorava la propria qualità della vita
e quindi la qualità della vita delle
persone nel proprio ambiente
e quindi quando lui mi ha rivelato la
sua meta
Io ho pensato Accidenti interessante ma
non era il mio mondo io non ne capivo
niente
arrivavo Tra l'altro da un mondo che era
quello del lusso delle fragranze dei
cosmetici No prima di essere un
formatore e quindi lontana anni luce ma
che cosa è accaduto è accaduto che lui
non solo mi ha rivelato la sua no E tra
l'altro me l'ha venduta molto bene
perché la prima volta che da Torino Ho
preso la mia macchina Sono arrivata a
Genova tutta quella azienda che lui mi
aveva descritto non c'era e io ho girato
ho girato convinta di aver sbagliato
luogo ed è brava Torinese diceva Vabbè
adesso mi prenderanno in giro perché qua
ci sono tutte ste viottole Si caruggi
certo non mi ero sbagliata lui sì aveva
un'azienda che infatti era fatta di
persone ma era dentro un garage deve
essere che questi garage portano buono e
tra l'altro raccogliermi la prima
risorsa che sia piaciuto era un ragazzo
insomma un po' più attempato di me e che
prima ha fatto un bel tiro della
sigaretta
no ha aspirato bene e poi per dirmi
quando io gli ho chiesto Ma è qua
acrobatica lui mi ha buttato mi avvolta
nella nuvola di fumo e mi ha detto sì e
sono entrata dentro le cuffie di cemento
e c'era la famosa azienda ora la stringo
Che cos'è che è accaduto di meraviglioso
che vedi lui ha ascoltato anche la mia
di Meta e questo è il primo punto ed è
uno delle dei Principi cardine del
nostro gruppo quello di ascoltare e di
interessarci alla meta e i sogni delle
persone perché vedi il punto è no tu da
imprenditore hai una meta grande che
puoi condividere ma il punto è
attraverso la tua meta queste persone
riusciranno a realizzare la propria E
allora Riccardo è stato illuminato
perché mi ha detto Ma tu con me la puoi
realizzare E infatti ragazzi è andata
così Però in quel lontano 2007 appunto
c'erano queste 12 persone e io ho detto
devo partire da qui da quello che c'è ed
erano gli anni in cui il buon Stephen
covey che io ancora conosciuto in vita e
ci ripeteva un paradigma importante da
cambiare il suo primo comincia partendo
dalla fine e infatti io ho cominciato ad
osservare queste persone e ho visto che
avevo dei diamanti
e dovevo solo trovare il sistema per
trasformare Appunto quello che è in
realtà erano gemme grezze da aiutare
Ecco che da lì Grazie a questo cambio di
paradigma e quindi di iniziare a vedere
le mie persone come l'unica vera materia
prima per la prosperità mi ha permesso
di fare che cosa di dedicarmi a loro
tutto ha inizio con una casetta di
cartone comprata in una in una
cartoleria che conteneva 12 bustine
nelle quali però Ognuno di loro
ed erano no provenivano da parti
differenti del mondo
poteva segnare i suoi desideri tutto è
partito da lì certo no per poter poi
sostenere la realizzazione è necessario
prendersi cura delle persone Io in
questo sono un po' provocatrice oggi
posso dire la nostra azienda è quotata
doppiamente No in borsa sia in Italia
che in Francia e quindi è tutto esposto
e vi inviterei ad andare a guardare la
percentuale dell'investimento che viene
fatto perché parliamo di capitale umano
e quindi se è capitale quanto siamo
disposti ad investire
partendo cominciando proprio dalla fine
è più facile perché le persone sono già
persone che hanno no vinto e quindi
cos'è che resta resta di costruire un
processo per poterle accompagnare a
realizzare i propri sogni ed è così che
è nata la Academy un luogo dove tutte
queste persone ma all'inizio ovviamente
quei famosi amici muratori che vi ho
descritto hanno cominciato a trovare un
luogo sicuro dove contenuti altamente
valoriali gli avevano una mano a fare
che cosa ad identificare allo stesso
modo come si faceva partire cominciando
dalla fine quindi conoscendo le loro
mete aiutandoli a programmarle
cominciando a lavorare su quelle che
sono le abitudini perché sono le
abitudini a causare i nostri risultati e
noi spesso lo dimentichiamo e quando
parlo di abitudini parlo del fatto che
tutti noi abbiamo un pilota automatico
che ripete idee azioni e anche cose che
ottiene E allora vedi per poter fare
quello che è No avevo immaginato cioè
lavorare su queste gemme grezze affinché
potessero risplendere e c'era bisogno di
prendersene cura e vedi nel processo di
crescita non per generare la prosperità
e per essere per ottenere persone che
sono davvero motivate non basta no Le ri
buone relazioni il processo è importante
e necessità anche che cosa un attenta
misurazione quindi la diffusione di una
cultura vera e propria sul amare i dati
i numeri perché i numeri raccontano
molto più
molte delle persone mi conoscono mi
vedono tanto spiritual io in realtà sono
talebana sui dati perché sono l'unico
modo che ho per manifestare davvero
quanto quanto mi stanno a cuore le
persone e noi lo sappiamo perché già in
natura Io sono doppiamente nonna e sono
neon da pochi mesi di una splendida
bambina e della quale però sapevo già
molto prima perché oggi noi non è
neanche ancora attivato l'ovulazione già
misuriamo vedi E poi misuriamo ancora ma
misuriamo perché siamo dei fanatici o
perché questo ci garantisce di poter
accompagnare le persone Allora ecco che
ha cominciato a diffondersi questa
cultura dove le persone apprezzano la
valorizzazione e la misurazione delle
proprie performance intermedie perché
vedi cominciare partendo dalla fine
vuole anche dire ma
Ho capito Abbiamo un sistema per
chiarire alle nostre persone davvero
qual è il risultato in fondo che tutte
le azioni che mettono in campo poi deve
generare perché guarda è diverso faccio
un esempio banale
normalmente un venditore no se gli
domando Qual è il suo risultato spesso
dice parla di vendita ma non è un
risultato la vendita è una occasione
parziale un'azione Diciamo che serve uno
degli ingredienti ma di solito un
commerciale un venditore è lì per
produrre un risultato ben più grande una
rete di clienti che ne saranno in un
certo modo e una rete che cresce
costantemente perché se è qualcosa non
cresce Di fatto si contrae e quindi
un'educazione basata su che cosa sul
riconoscere quanto possiamo essere
contributivi
perché
le persone non è che faticano non
scambiano perché sono lavative perché
non vogliono molto spesso non le persone
non arrivano a realizzare delle
performance non perché Attiva volontà ma
semplicemente perché perché sono lì con
la testa bassa dedicate al fare un po'
Come il nostro
amico muratore dell'inizio con la testa
piegata le Mani gonfie e tanta fatica
Beh vedi
Questa è la storia di una porzione di un
decennio di 15 anni di vita Ecco io
vorrei ritornare
di Ecco una cosa che faccio sempre che
non uso le slide ragazzi per cui
sarebbero del tutto inutili per me nella
vita
di solito c'è qualcuno che lo fa per me
perché io poi quando ho finito
l'intervento di qua Cavoli ci sono le
slide le persone al centro Beh ho detto
tutto quello che è che c'era Eh però è
importante anche vedere alcune immagini
di questi famosi muratori Ecco che quel
muratore è stanco
affaticato ha un po' cambiato si è
trasformato oggi una persona che cammina
a testa alta e non solo perché vede le
cose dall'alto perché è diventato un
operatore specializzato su fune vedi Lui
è diventato un wallmen bum E sono i
wolmevo sono gli uomini Mura No ma non
spagnolo Perché vedi quando io ho
iniziato visto che è Francesca No prima
ha ricordato che mi sono occupata certo
della selezione ma vi immaginate quanta
attrazione c'era negli anni 2007 nel
settore dell'edilizia per poter assumere
dei muratori
veramente poco senza questo cambio di
cultura non ce l'avremmo fatta io allora
facevo una fatica incredibile solo a
ricevere dei curricula oggi vi do un
numero nel 2022 abbiamo ricevuto per
solo la figura professionale del
muratore
37.900
curricula quindi
[Applauso]
Perché Perché siamo diventati attrattivi
anche per le donne perché non è più solo
un lavoro di fatica perché vedi il
wall-man V non è più quel muratore
affaticato un muratore che va fiero che
ha alzato la testa perché non è più solo
numero uno nello scambiare il suo lavoro
quindi è il ripristino la muratura ma è
diventato numero uno nelle relazioni e
vedi bisogna Come dice il mio maestro
concluderei perché sono riuscita a
terminare l'unica che è andata fuori
tempo grande questo è no ci avrei ci
potevamo scommettere vero i miei amici
di Mab & co lo sanno bene vado in
conclusione a questa però era bella per
dirvi oggi
i nostri Wolverine buono sono 2200 sono
un po' di meno perché ci sono ci sono
anche le persone dietro le quinte che
fanno che soste quello che permettono a
loro l'evoluzione Ecco sono persone che
hanno la consapevolezza che quando
arrivano no a scambiare dall'altra parte
ci sono persone loro sono il nostro
primo cliente ma è l'unico modo è
l'unico vero Atto di fede per il cliente
finale E come dice il mio maestro e con
questo No concludo Io sono buddista da
tanti anni Questa è stata una grande
Fonte d'ispirazione per me piuttosto che
giudicare le persone come Capaci o
incapaci è meglio cercare i loro punti
di forza
la crescita di persone Capaci dipende
dalla determinazione dei suoi
responsabili dei loro responsabili noi
[Applauso]
Grazie
grazie Va a loro questa appunto nuova
figura professionale ha permesso Allora
di cambiare davvero la cultura no di un
mestiere E poi un'altra cosa oggi io
vedo giovani che sono tornati No con la
voglia nel cuore di
affrontare questo mestiere che è una
nostra tradizione e che davvero quando
parliamo di Made in Italy nel mondo
insomma noi in questo siamo veramente
numeri uno e non solo vedete questa
immagine no raccontano una piccola parte
di un grande sogno quando hai persone
che sposano le mete che condividono i
valori che contribuiscono al gruppo che
imparano che si motivano che vivono e
che sono spinti dall'entusiasmo si
possono realizzare dei sogni incredibili
e questi stessi wormann insieme ad altri
i gruppi di volontari
mi hanno permesso di realizzare questo
grande sogno di un'associazione no
profita appena non ho che appena stata
riconosciuta al terzo settore e sono i
supereroi che si chiamano dai tetti di
tutti gli ospedali pediatrici da ormai 8
anni in tutta Italia non solo a portare
il sorriso ai bambini questo per me per
noi è il capitale umano Grazie